Maligayang pagbabalik sa Quantum Computing in Practice. Ito ay episode 6. Ngayon magtutuon tayo sa isa sa aking mga paboritong
aplikasyon ng mga quantum computer, ang pag-simulate ng kalikasan. Sa episode na ito, tatalakayin natin ang mga hakbang na kinakailangan
para gawin ito para sa anumang uri ng problema sa quantum dynamics, na siyang problema ng paghahanap kung paano nagbabago ang paglalarawan ng isang
quantum system sa paglipas ng panahon. Gagawin natin ito sa mataas na antas muna at pagkatapos ay tititig sa isang tiyak na halimbawa at lalakad
nang detalyado dito. lalo na ang 2023 IBM experiment na nagpakita ng quantum utility. Para sa ilang mabilis na motibasyon sa
simula, isa sa mga pinakasikat na kwento na pag-uusapan namin sa larangang ito ng quantum computing nang paulit-ulit,
ang kwento ni Richard Feynman na nagbibigay ng leksyon sa Caltech noong 1959 at basically
nagbibigay ng motibasyon para sa buong larangan ng mga dekada. Ang talumpati ay tinatawag na "There's Plenty of Room at the
Bottom." isang nakakatuwang titulo, ngunit ang pangunahing ideya ay nagkukuwento siya na marami pa ring mayamang pisika na
matutuklas sa microscopic na antas.
Ngayon, ang tiyak na talumpati na iyon ay hindi gaanong pinagtutuunan ng pansin hanggang sa 80s nang ang teknolohiya ay medyo lumago na nang kaunti. At si Feynman
ay naglinawin at pinino rin ang kanyang mensahe sa paglipas ng panahon. Bumalik siya sa Caltech noong 80s at nagpresenta ng isa pang papel na tinatawag na
Simulating Nature with Computers kung saan sinabi niya nang tiyak na gusto niyang pag-usapan ang posibilidad na mayroong
eksaktong simulation na gagawin ng computer nang eksaktong katulad ng kalikasan.
essentially nagagawa na alisin ang magastos na approximation ng kung ano ang nagaganap sa atomic scale at palitan ang mga ito ng
mga computer na nakakaunawa at gumagamit ng quantum physics hindi lamang para i-simulate ang ginagawa ng kalikasan, kundi gayahin ito.
Ngayon, alalahanin ang timeline graphic na ito na ipinakita ko sa nakaraang episode. Sa isang dulo, mayroon tayong mga problema na madaling
malutas at hindi mangangailangan ng anumang uri ng speedup na maaaring mag-alok ang quantum. Ngunit sa kabilang dulo, mayroon tayong mga problema na
napakahirap at nangangailangan ng fault tolerant na mga quantum machine na wala pa tayo.
Sa kabutihang palad, naniniwala tayo na mayroong medyo maraming mga problema sa simulation na narito sa gitna, na siyang rehiyon na
kasalukuyan tayong makakatrabaho. At maraming dahilan para maging sabik at mausisa sa pananawang ito dahil ang
pag-simulate ng kalikasan ay batayan ng maraming kapana-panabik na lugar ng aplikasyon. ilang halimbawa lamang. Kung mas mahusay tayong
mag-simulate ng kalikasan, maaari tayong pabilisin ang pagtuklas ng mga bagong materyales, lumikha ng mas mahusay na mga gamot at gamutan, o
kahit matuklasan ang bagong pisika na pinagbabatayan ng particle physics o cosmology. Ngunit bago ka o ako o sinuman ay makasubukan
ng pag-apply ng quantum computing sa mga kapana-panabik na larangang ito sa ngayon, kakailanganing maunawaan ang mga pangunahing hakbang sa isang
karaniwang simulation-based na workflow.
Una, gusto mong tukuyin ang isang quantum system na may interes. Ito ay magbibigay-alam sa iyo tungkol sa Hamiltonian na namamahala sa oras ng
ebolusyon nito at isang makabuluhang paglalarawan ng mga panimulang katangian nito o ng estado nito.
Pagkatapos ay kailangan mong mahanap ang angkop na pamamaraan para ipatupad ang oras na ebolusyon ng estado na ito. Sa mga sangkap na ito
na naayos na, ang mga susunod na hakbang ay kinabibilangan ng pagsasagawa ng aktwal na eksperimento.
Ang mga ito ay karaniwang kinabibilangan ng pag-optimize ng quantum circuit na implementasyon ng time evolution algorithm, pagpapatakbo ng
circuit o mga circuit sa quantum hardware at post-processing ng mga resulta. Kaya
maaari nating pangalanan ang mga pangunahing hakbang na kasangkot sa isang simulation experiment tulad ng sumusunod.
Ang pagtukoy sa system Hamiltonian, Hamiltonian encoding, paghahanda ng estado, ebolusyon ng estado,
pag-optimize ng circuit, pagpapatakbo ng circuit, at post-processing.
Ngunit ang mga ito ay medyo detalyadong hakbang. Alalahanin na ang apat na yugto ng Qiskit patterns framework, na tumutulong
sa atin na maunawaan kung paano ipatupad ang isang routine sa Qiskit ay mapping, pag-optimize ng circuit, pagpapatakbo ng circuit, at
post-processing. Kaya ang apat na unang hakbang na ito ay aktwal na kasama lahat sa ilalim ng payong ng mapping at iyan ang
dahilan kung bakit gumugol tayo ng isang buong episode sa unang yugto na ito at kung napalampas mo iyon pakiusap bumalik at panoorin ang nakaraang episode.
Ngayon una tayong lalakad sa kung ano ang ibig sabihin ng mga hakbang na ito bago pa tayo sumisid sa anumang coding. Kaya ang unang pangunahing bagay na kailangan
nating gawin para magsagawa ng simulation experiment ay tukuyin ang Hamiltonian na naglalarawan sa sistema. Minsan kilala
ang mga ito nang maayos, minsan kailangan nating tipunin ito mula sa pag-unawa sa mga kontribusyon ng enerhiya
ng maliliit na subset ng buong sistema tulad nito kung saan ang hi ay ang Hamiltonian na kumikilos sa isa sa n na subsystem ng h.
Kailangan din nating tandaan kung ang sistema ay binubuo ng mga fermion o boson kung may pakikitungo tayo sa mga elementary particle. Susunod,
kailangan nating i-encode ang Hamiltonian at isalin ito sa mga termino na maiintindihan ng mga quantum computer. Madalas,
ang mga Hamiltonian na ito ay binubuo ng mga elementary particle o spin system. Kung nagsi-simulate tayo ng mga fermion o boson,
kailangan nating pumili ng encoding transformation tulad ng Jordan-Wigner o Bravyi-Kitaev. Ang mga transformation na ito ay
magsasabi sa atin kung paano isalin ang kahulugan ng Hamiltonian na nakasulat sa mga tuntunin ng mga orihinal na bahagi, ang mga fermion o
boson, sa mga Pauli operator na madaling na-convert sa mga gate sa isang quantum computer. Halimbawa, ang Jordan-Wigner
transformation na tinukoy dito ay nagbibigay ng mapping mula sa mga fermion operator patungong Pauli operator. Kung mayroon na tayong pakikitungo sa
mga spin 1/2 system na napakakaraniwan ay maayos na tayo maliban sa anumang posibleng normalization coefficient
at hindi natin kailangan ng encoding scheme. Pagkatapos ng pag-encode ng nais na Hamiltonian sa gate set ng quantum computer,
ang susunod na mahalagang hakbang ay ang pagtukoy ng angkop na paunang quantum state mula sa kung saan sisimulan ang ating
simulation. Ang estado na ito ay perpektong sumasalamin sa ilang pisikal na kahulugan o configuration ng
sistema na pinag-aaralan. Halimbawa, kung interesado tayo sa pagtuklas ng ground state energy ng isang molekula, maaari tayong
magsimula sa isang Hartree-Fock approximation o isa pang madaling ihahanda na ansatz na may malaking overlap sa tunay na
ground state. Ang pagpili ng paunang ground state ay nakakaapekto hindi lamang sa convergence ng mga variational algorithm
tulad ng VQE na variational quantum solver kundi pati na rin sa katumpakan at kahusayan ng
oras na ebolusyon o sampling sa quantum phase estimation. Sa esensya, ang paunang estado ay nagsisilbing
panimulang punto para sa computation na nagtatakda ng yugto para sa pagkuha ng mga kapaki-pakinabang na observable tungkol sa quantum system
na aming modelo. ang paghahanda ng isang arbitrary na n qubit state kung saan ang ci ay ang mga computational basis state at ang ai ay ang
kaukulang coefficient ng bawat estado at ang normalization condition na 2 n minus isa ay maaaring pangkalahatang lapitan sa pamamagitan ng
pagsisimula ng estado gamit ang operator o ang panimulang estado ay magiging all-zero standard basis state na madalas na nakasulat
ganito para sa simplipikasyon sa pangkalahatan ito ay nangangailangan ng exponential na bilang ng c not gate madalas na interesado tayo sa
tiyak na paunang estado para sa sistema at ang paghahanda nito ay maaaring ipatupad nang may makatwirang dami
ng mga resources. Ang mga product state halimbawa kung saan ang mga qubit ay hindi entangled sa isa't isa ay nangangailangan lamang ng single
qubit na operasyon. Ngayon wala pa tayong pagkakataon na pag-usapan ang trotterization
bagama't malamang na pamilyar na ang ilan sa inyo rito. Sa esensya, ang trotterization ay isang pamamaraan para sa pagkalkula ng matrix exponentiation na
gumagamit ng mga approximation para harapin ang exponential na katangian ng mga non-commutative operator. Kapag ang dalawang operator tulad ng HA
at HB ay hindi nag-commute, dapat tayong gumamit ng matalinong trick at alternately mag-apply ng kaukulang exponential ng
e sa i ha at e sa i hb para sa n na bilang ng
beses na inilalapat ang mga alternating evolution operator. Hindi ko sasaliksikin ang patunay dito, ngunit magbabahagi ako ng link
sa isang magandang simpleng patunay ng pahayag na ito sa paglalarawan. Ngunit ang take-home message ay ito. Ang oras na ebolusyon ay isang
mahalagang bahagi ng mapping din. Ang trotterization ay nahahati ng patuloy na interaksyon sa mga discrete na hakbang na maaaring
ipatupad sa isang quantum computer. Pagkatapos ng paglikha ng trotterized circuit, natapos na natin
ang hakbang ng mapping. Maaari na tayong lumipat sa pag-optimize ng circuit.
Para gawin iyon, ito ang kailangang makamit. Dapat mayroong qubit layout na nagma-map ng mga virtual qubit ng
iyong circuit sa mga pisikal na qubit sa hardware. Kailangan ito dahil ang hardware ay maaaring may mga partikular na topology
na nagpapatakbo sa direktang interaksyon ng mga pisikal na qubit. Habang ang implementasyon ng isang
quantum circuit ay kadalasang inaasumeng ang kakayahan ng anumang qubit na makipag-interact sa anumang ibang qubit. Pagkatapos ay kailangan nating mag-insert ng
mga swap gate kung kinakailangan para iruta ang mga interaksyon sa pagitan ng mga qubit na hindi konektado. Kailangan nating isalin ang
mga gate sa ating circuit sa instruction set architecture o ISA instruction na
maaaring direktang maipatupad sa hardware. Pagkatapos ay kailangan nating magsagawa ng mga pag-optimize ng circuit para mabawasan ang
circuit depth at gate count. Ang hakbang na ito ay maaari ring isagawa sa virtual circuit. Ang circuit kung saan ang mga qubit
ay hindi pa na-map sa isang device topology. Ngunit tandaan na karamihan sa ito ay awtomatikong ginagawa para sa iyo sa
Qiskit. Makikita natin kung paano eksakto sa susunod na seksyon ng leksyong ito. Pagkatapos ng hakbang ng pag-optimize, handa na tayong patakbuhin
ang circuit gamit ang isang primitive. Para sa karamihan ng mga simulation experiment, interesado kang maunawaan ang pagbabago
ng ilang katangian ng sistema sa paglipas ng panahon. Kaya malamang na gagamitin mo ang estimator primitive dahil
pinahihintulutan kang sukatin ang mga expectation value ng mga observable na tumutugma sa mga tiyak na katangian. Pagkatapos ay
i-configure natin ang pinakamabuting mga opsyon para sa estimator na maaaring magdagdag ng mga teknik ng error suppression at error mitigation. Sa wakas, ipapatakbo natin ang
eksperimento. Ang huling hakbang ay ang post-process ng lahat ng data. Kinukuha nito ang mga nasukat na expectation value o kung
gumagamit ka ng sampler, ang sample probability distribution sa computational basis. Kung ang kailangan lamang
ay ang mga expectation value ng mga observable ng interes, ang mga ito ay maaaring direktang makuha mula sa estimator
primitive sa parehong raw at error-mitigated na mga halaga. Madalas na gagamitin ng isa ang mga nasukat na expectation value
para sa iba pang mga kalkulasyon para sa iba pang mga dami ng interes na hindi nangangailangan ng quantum computation at maaaring
ma-compute sa isang klasikal na computer.
Ngayon lalakad tayo sa isang tunay na halimbawa mula sa isang napaka-influential na papel na inilathala ng IBM ilang taon na ang nakalipas na tinatawag na
"Evidence for Utility of Quantum Computing Before Fault Tolerance." Ngayon ang papel na ito na pinaikli nating mahal bilang
utility paper ay naging isang napaka-influential na papel sa larangan ng quantum computing halos agad pagkatapos ng publikasyon.
Ang pangkalahatang thesis ng papel ay ang isang maingay na quantum computer ay nakagawa ng tumpak na mga resulta o expectation value
gamit ang 127 qubit at 2,880 gate na higit sa kakayahan ng brute
force computation na siyang eksaktong simulation ng mga quantum circuit na isinasagawa ng hardware. Ang gawaing ito ay
mahalaga rin dahil nagpakita ito na ang isang quantum computer ay maaaring gamitin para i-verify o ikumpara ang mga resulta sa iba pang
approximate na klasikal na pamamaraan para sa mga quantum simulation tulad ng mga tensor network algorithm kung saan ang solusyon
ay hindi kilala nang a priori. Ang isa pang napaka-cool na bagay ay ang ngayon ang iba ay gumagamit ng IBM quantum system sa
cloud at Qiskit ay maaaring mag-duplicate at i-verify ang mga resultang ito nang sila mismo.
Ipapakita ko sa iyo kung paano gawin iyon. Kaya para sa halimbawang ito, magiging mas tiyak tayo tungkol sa mga
hakbang na kasangkot sa pag-map ng problemang ito sa mga input na maiintindihan ng isang quantum device. Sa kasong ito, kami ay
magsi-simulate ng dynamics ng kabuuang magnetization ng isang sistema ng mga magnetic dipole spin sa isang lattice sa
presensya ng isang external na magnetic field. Ang sistema ay maaaring ilarawan ng isang Ising model na may transverse magnetic field.
Inimo-modelo natin ito gamit ang isang parameterized na quantum circuit kung saan ang mga parameter ay tumutugma sa nababago na halaga ng
spin-spin o z interaction at ang lakas ng magnetic field na X. Ngayon,
ang seryeng ito ay tinatawag na quantum computing in practice. Kaya, tatalakayin din natin ang mga pamamaraan sa eksperimentong ito
na ipapatupad natin para gawing pinakamahusay ang mga resulta. Kaya susunod na tatalakayin natin kung paano alisin
ang masamang qubit o ang mga qubit na may mababang gate fidelity o decoherence time na maaaring lubhang makaapekto sa
mga resulta ng eksperimento. Ang mga masamang qubit na ito ay maaaring mangyari dahil sa masamang calibration noon
o two-level system na nakikipag-interact sa qubit. Ang pag-alis ng ilang qubit mula sa hardware native topology ay katumbas ng
pagsasaalang-alang ng isang sistema sa isang lattice na inilarawan ng resultang topology. Tatalakayin din natin ang paglikha ng
parameterized na quantum circuit na nagpapatupad ng oras na ebolusyon ng sistema sa pamamagitan ng trotterization.
Para sa layuning ito, mahalaga na tukuyin ang mga entangling layer na isang kritikal na bahagi para sa pangunahing error
mitigation technique na gagamitin natin sa ibang pagkakataon. Kaya sa puntong ito gusto kong tiyakin na ikaw ang audience ay alam
na maaari kang sumabay sa lahat ng aking tatalakayin sa tutorial na naka-link sa ibaba at sa IBM
quantum learning platform. Sa tutorial na ito, maaaring mapansin mo na lumikha kami ng isang serye ng mga helper
function sa simula ng notebook na maaari naming tawagin sa ibang pagkakataon para mas mapagaan ang aming buhay. Gusto kong banggitin ang mga
ito ngayon, hindi dahil ito ay bahagi ng opisyal o pormal na proseso, kundi dahil ito ang madalas na ginagawa ng mga eksperimentalista
sa tunay na buhay para matulungan silang patakbuhin ang mga ganitong uri ng eksperimento. At nagpapakita rin ito sa atin kung paano natin pahahabaín ang ating
problema nang higit pa. Ang mga function na tinutukoy natin sa notebook ay tulad ng sumusunod. Alisin ang qubit coupling.
Tukuyin ang mga qubit coupling. Itayo ang mga layer coupling. Itayo ang mga entangling layer. At sa wakas, tukuyin ang trotterized
circuit. Susunod, pag-usapan natin ang mga layer coupling, na tumutulong sa pagtukoy kung paano nag-i-interact ang mga qubit
sa kanilang mga kapitbahay sa panahon ng simulation. Ang aming mga quantum device ay gumagamit ng isang bagay na tinatawag na heavy hexagonal
layout. Isang espesyal na pattern para sa pag-kokonekta ng mga qubit. Sa layout na ito, maaari tayong pangkatin ang mga koneksyon na tinatawag na mga gilid sa tatlong
magkahiwalay na set kung saan walang dalawang koneksyon sa parehong set ay nagbabahagi ng qubit. Ito ay
mahalaga dahil sa isang tunay na quantum computer, hindi natin maaaring patakbuhin ang dalawang qubit gate nang sabay kung kinabibilangan ang mga ito ng
parehong qubit. Ang bawat qubit ay maaari lamang kasangkot sa isang gate sa isang pagkakataon. Sa pamamagitan ng
paghahati ng lahat ng koneksyon sa tatlong layer, maaari tayong mag-apply ng dalawang qubit gate sa buong device sa tatlong
round, na tinitiyak na walang qubit na ginagamit sa higit sa isang gate bawat layer. Ang mga
gate na ito ay nagpapatupad ng ZZ interaction mula sa Ising model, at inuulit ang mga ito sa bawat hakbang ng simulation na tinatawag na
Trotter step. Binabago ng twirling ang ingay sa device para kahit isang simpleng modelo ng ingay
ay malamang na magiging tumpak. Ginagawa rin nitong posible na tumpak na matutunan ang modelo ng ingay at gamitin ang nakuhang
impormasyon sa mga teknik ng error mitigation.
Susunod, kailangan nating alisin ang ating mga masamang qubit mula sa ating posibleng listahan ng mga pisikal na qubit na maaari nating gamitin para sa
eksperimento. Gaya ng aking sinabi, ang isang qubit ay maaaring maging masama dahil sa iba't ibang dahilan. Minsan ito ay masamang
calibration lamang, isang simpleng pagkakamali na maaaring malutas sa pamamagitan ng muling calibration.
Minsan ito ay medyo mas kumplikado at may kaugnayan sa isang bagay na tinatawag naming TLS, na isang two-level interfacial
defect na humahantong sa mga pagbabago ng qubit parameter at relaxation. Maaaring
ito ay malutas sa pamamagitan ng pagpainit ng buong sistema nang kaunti at pagkatapos ay pagpapalamig nito. Ngunit nangangailangan ito ng oras at hindi posible
na gawin sa cloud. Kaya sa ngayon, ang pinakamadaling gawin ay ang ibukod na lamang ang mga ito mula sa ating listahan ng posibleng pisikal
na qubit na gagamitin natin. Madali mong matukoy kung aling mga qubit ang hindi gumagana ayon sa inaasahan mula sa IBM quantum platform.
Maaari mong i-plot ang mga katangian ng qubit doon sa platform o i-download ang mga ito bilang CSV. Pagkatapos ay lumikha ng listahan ng lahat ng
qubit na gusto mong ibukod at alisin na lang ang mga ito mula sa listahan ng kabuuang pisikal na qubit sa device.
Sige. Ngayon ituloy natin ang ating hakbang ng mapping na bumubuo ng ating trotterized circuit. Gaya ng ipinakita namin
nang mas maaga ang trotterization ay nagdi-discretize ng oras na ebolusyon sa isang serye ng mga hakbang at kailangan nating magpasya kung ilang hakbang.
Pipili tayo ng anim dito. Ngunit sa pangkalahatan ang istratehiya ay ang pagbabalanse ng isang bagay na tinatawag na Trotter error na isang
algorithmic approximation error sa error na nagmumula sa decoherence. Ang mas maraming Trotter step ay nagpapababa ng approximation
error ngunit nangangailangan ng mas malalim na mga quantum circuit na nakakaranas ng mas maraming decoherence noise. Tutukuyin natin ang
circuit sa mga tuntunin ng theta parameter na siyang lakas ng external magnetic field layer coupling at ang
bilang ng mga hakbang at qubit at siyempre ang device backend. Dahil sa
depende ng magnetization ng sistema sa lakas ng external magnetic field, kawili-wili
patakbuhin ang simulation sa iba't ibang halaga ng lakas ng magnetic field na nagsasalin sa iba't ibang anggulo ng RX sa
rotation para sa RX sa circuit. Ngayon na nalikha na natin ang ating circuit, lilipat tayo sa pag-optimize nito.
Ang unang hakbang dito ay ang tukuyin ang isang pass manager. Tandaan na sa konteksto ng Qiskit SDK, ang transpilation ay tumutukoy sa
proseso ng pag-transform ng input circuit sa isang anyo na angkop para sa pagpapatakbo sa isang quantum device.
Ang transpilation ay karaniwang nangyayari sa isang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga hakbang na tinatawag na transpiler pass. Ang pass manager ay isang object na
nag-iimbak ng listahan ng mga transpiler pass at maaaring isagawa ang mga ito sa isang circuit. Lumikha ng pass manager sa pamamagitan ng pagsisimula ng isang pass
manager object na may listahan ng mga transpiler pass. Sa huli, ang ating pass manager
ay lilikha ng isang ISA circuit, isang circuit na dapat nakasulat sa mga tuntunin ng instruction set architecture ng backend,
na naglalarawan ng circuit at mga gate na katutubong sa backend ngunit kulang ang timing na impormasyon na kailangan para patakbuhin ang
circuit. Ngayon handa na tayong isagawa ang ating circuit na siyang ikatlong hakbang ng Qiskit pattern. Tulad ng nabanggit nang mas maaga, gagamitin
natin ang estimator bilang ating napiling primitive para sa eksperimentong ito dahil gusto nating sukatin ang
kabuuang magnetization ng sistema at ang pagtatantya ng expectation value ng mga observable ay kung para saan dinisenyo ang estimator
para doon. Sa hakbang na ito mahalaga rin na tukuyin ang ating mga opsyon para sa error mitigation. Gagamitin natin ang zero noise
extrapolation para makakuha ng pinakamabuting posibleng mga resulta. Lalo na sa tutorial, makikita mo na tinutukoy natin ng dalawa o higit pa
na mga halaga ng noise factor kung saan susuriin ang mga extrapolated na modelo at tinutukoy
ang probabilistic error amplification bilang ating opsyon sa amplification. Ngayon, ang probabilistic
error amplification o PA ay talagang ang napiling pamamaraan ng error mitigation dito dahil nag-i-scale ito nang napaka-
maayos kaysa sa iba pang mga opsyon. At iyon ang mahalaga kapag nagtatrabaho tayo sa antas ng 100 dagdag na qubit.
Huli ngunit hindi bababa, patakbuhin ang eksperimento at aabutin ito ng ilang oras upang makumpleto, ngunit sa ngayon, i-reference natin ang data
na nakapila at naimbak mula sa tutorial. Susuriin natin ang metadata na espesyal na mapapansin ang layered gate at
ang mga mitigated layer dahil gagamitin natin ang mga ito upang alisin ang maraming error mula sa aming raw data. Malapit na tayong
i-plot ang ating mga final na resulta. Ngunit bago gawin iyon, mabilis na magdagdag ng interlude dito kung ano ang eksakto ang ibig sabihin ng zero
noise extrapolation o ZNE. Tinakpan natin ito nang maikli sa mga nakaraang episode, ngunit para ma-review, ang zero noise extrapolation
ay isang teknik ng error mitigation na inaalis ang mga epekto ng isang hindi kilalang ingay sa panahon ng pagpapatakbo ng circuit na maaaring
i-scale sa isang kilalang paraan. Inaasumeng ang mga expectation value ay nag-i-scale sa ingay sa pamamagitan ng isang kilalang function na ipinakita dito kung saan ang
ang mga lambda parameter ay tinutukoy ang lakas ng ingay at maaaring i-amplify. Maaari nating ipatupad ang ZNE gamit ang mga sumusunod na hakbang.
Una, i-amplify ang circuit noise para sa ilang noise factor. Lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, at iba pa. Patakbuhin ang bawat noise-amplified na circuit para sukatin ang
expectation value na a ng lambda 1, a ng lambda 2, at iba pa. At pagkatapos ay i-extrapolate pabalik sa zero noise
limit, ang expectation value na a ng zero.
Ang pangunahing hamon sa matagumpay na pagpapatupad ng ZNE ay ang pagkakaroon ng tumpak na modelo para sa ingay sa expectation value
at para i-amplify ang ingay sa kilalang paraan.
Mayroong tatlong karaniwang paraan na ipinapatupad ang error amplification para sa ZNE: i-scale ang pulse duration sa pamamagitan ng calibration,
ulitin ang mga gate sa mga identity cycle at magdagdag ng ingay sa pamamagitan ng pag-sample ng mga Pauli channel.
Tinatawag natin ang huli na PA. Ang probabilistic error amplification ay ang pinakamahusay na pagpipilian dito dahil ang pulse stretching ay napaka-
computationally costly. Ang gate folding ay kulang ng mga teoretikal na garantiya sa pangangalaga ng noise bias. Ngunit ang PA ay maaaring
ilapat sa anumang circuit na maaaring patakbuhin na may mga native noise factor ngunit nangangailangan ng pag-aaral ng modelo ng ingay. Inaasumeng ng PA ang
parehong layer-based na modelo ng ingay gaya ng probabilistic error cancellation.
Gayunpaman, iniilag nito ang sampling overhead na nag-i-scale nang exponentially sa circuit noise. Para matuto ang modelo ng ingay,
dapat muna tayong tukuyin ang mga natatanging layer ng dalawang qubit na operasyon sa circuit.
Para sa bawat layer, Pauli-twirl ang mga dalawang qubit gate para tiyaking ang ingay ay maayos na inilarawan ng damping noise model.
Ulitin ang mga identity pair ng mga layer sa iba't ibang lalim at sa wakas ay i-fit ang fidelity o error para sa bawat noise channel. At
siyempre, habang inirerekomenda ko ang pag-unawa sa pamamaraang ito sa ilang lawak, ang paggawa nito nang kamay sa Qiskit ay
mas simple tulad ng ipinakita sa tutorial. Ngayon, sa wakas, tingnan natin ang plotted na data. Ang dotted
grey na linya ay nagpapakita ng eksaktong mga resulta na nakuha gamit ang mga approximate na klasikal na pamamaraan na may approximation error
na nag-converge sa mababang threshold. Tulad ng nakikita mo, ang raw data para sa iba't ibang noise factor na pinili natin sa
simula ay malayo mula sa dotted na linya. Ang solid na asul na linya ay nagpapakita ng data na isinasaalang-alang ang aming ZNE
na pagpoproseso. At agad mong mamamalas na mas malapit ito sa eksaktong mga resulta.
Sa buod, ang mga maingay na halaga ay nagpapakita ng mataas na paglihis mula sa eksaktong mga halaga. Ang
mga mitigated na halaga ay malapit sa eksaktong mga halaga, nagpapakita ng utility ng PA-based na teknik ng mitigation.
At iyon ay essentially nagwawakas sa episode na ito. Para mabilis na ibuod ang natutunan natin, ang quantum simulation ay isa
sa pinaka-promising na lugar ng aplikasyon sa maikling hanggang gitnang panahon.
Mayroon itong malawak na mga aplikasyon mula sa mga gamot hanggang sa high energy physics,
material science at iba pa. Ang utility paper mula sa IBM na inilathala noong 2023 ay nagpakita
ng daan patungo sa pagiging makapaggamit ng mga quantum computer para sa siyentipikong pagtuklas. At isinaayos natin ang
kaugnay na tutorial na kasama ang papel na iyon nang malalim. Ang mga hakbang para magtrabaho sa isang problema sa simulation mula simula
hanggang katapusan ay medyo simple, lalo na kapag nasanay ka na rito. At ang aking pag-asa ay
maaari mong gamitin mula ngayon ang video na ito at ang tutorial bilang gabay para sa higit pa pang mga problema sa simulation sa hinaharap.
Salamat sa panonood at kita tayo sa susunod na pagkakataon sa Quantum Computing in Practice.